now
it was up any gonna go back how's the
light is it low enough to what I so are
you
he's fit everything in yeah unless you
guys brought hello clothes sup teh yotei
you're bringing enough stuff you're
gonna fit all that stuff in gonna fit
all that stuff in the trunk this three
cameras having are we bringing three
cameras to check out my clothes right I
don't need your clothes Andy do you need
Andy do you need taste clothes you got a
piece with you bring the ps4 what do you
thought I was lying to want to play
video games so I'll play some diablo
tribbles trizol she didn't bring that
they did not be no time there you go sup
j hey are you ready for blizzard
convention 2014 cracking when i went
back upstairs Andy hey we're gonna
blizzard convention let's go to Blizzard
convention oh [ __ ] seatbelt off folks
we're gonna play some lizard video game
leave
by the way caught up gettin dough on the
list before I bake I know herbalist
green beetle in web to my vegetarian
teeth through the sunshine in step out
to take you to the beings await we came
by then raised up his name is down on me
sing with green leaving scars on the
tarmac spacewalks be spooning younger
kids you gonna pleasure convention to
its cool kid don't play Blizzard games
well drop out of school if you play pool
is your mouth
you get bad grades I jumped out of
school because of the Lost Vikings what
did you drop out of school because I
didn't drop out of anything I still had
in three
for is GPA while playing wow four or
five days a week they're college kids
believe local never miss class classes
I see
the kids knew her name was like Wilford
Brimley mMmmm and then here's TV game
and he killed someone someone else
that's the username was texted ivy how'd
you like be friends this is the most
American thing I've ever seen why why is
there a diabetes test handgun and this
McDonald's put that next orange juice
look fresh forget this hash brown on the
meeting 61 luckily I'm not in that range
of wait let me just move this hash brown
so i can see ya Howard r is going on I
guess I'm not even qualified do you have
frequent urination are you thirsty I do
hear any every day but every day
sometimes multiple oh my god you've got
the diabeetus
say doctor mistake
low in fat jack low in fat jack just
like the show
Justin explained the logo for this
petrol station gas station sorry hit the
gas station image Statue of Liberty it
seems to have been set on fire and is a
smoking burning
I
good
they're going to show you the mountains
in the background
he just like I play pissed if you don't
cool result by the game and aiming for a
drawer where the fun is being where he's
coming as I taxi push em anybody first
trapping in imax a cruising man busted
and don't stop Wikimedia Taylor Swift as
I did you learn
besides too emotional
shake it up
in the land this is dinner then dinner
justin is Daniel
Disneyland is technically part of
Disneyland is this the mighty ducks yeah
we're we're in their mighty ducks
where's Emilio Estevez like you guys any
more than just a duck where's many rest
of us I think in bloomers automating
Estevez there you can live in these
apartments just go to get hello sir is
my machine your father Oh stretch them
legs in SF but we're here hey pretty
good minus the sweatiness and the hawk
say oh you wore the shorts you were here
I were to the library on white boy pats
only mean it alters how do you feeling
I'm P&I time we got your waiter to how
long strip was like seven and a half I
mean if you he really killed it and like
wanted to like really go like yes I'm
like break the law even born yeah I'd be
like six and a half but we made a few
stops is good who's that it's good time
we left it like 6am so it feels like its
true like it's only one o'clock they on
him he's normal yeah I gotta get us in
telecom and I go sleep in this town
tomorrow just do it let's do it it's
none of the weird meal
it was really good now I feel like I'm
was good mistakes always no chicken stop
talking I tried to set the wrong [ __ ]
number announced today I'll just go drop
this ball this is a drop your ball
[ __ ] get your ball bro get your
ball bro yeah shut up for blizzcon sorry
you were saying that was an after school
special kid is gonna only watch football
it's the safest pick yep if adults
unless it's taco tuesday which
just bite the bullet and get three soft
tacos for
she got five tacos that I did hey my
[ __ ] time be on the call
hot dog
san Francisco's so got to go big
although I have a feeling this is
I ok way to us you can only hope you
tell me okay okay great fifth over the
last time a while ago hahaha I'm good
with that what do you think Jo yes then
that can be the first and last time on
this trip and of my life
this is weird we're saying the legit
house our minds got a garage hey she's
got a garage and a Subaru that knocking
at del taco on the floor like Nike DS
no your car managed to get us here oh
man I saw red all the way down oh look
at that just i hain't flat screen this
place smells like Clorox shower look at
this place got some icky masks cuz
Disneyland well I like this one leave
this one I want this sick CRT television
situation here [ __ ] TV vc or
combination really there's two bad
hahaha and there's two beds here oh who
wants to keep moving oh wait wait is
this is this legit for two people yes oh
really we have 50 I don't want to wish
like that we should flip coins right
there cuz i don't know i don't want to
just take that room no but look at who's
gonna get that room what that more room
is this oh this is john cowan oh very
nice room creepy ass this is yours oh
this there's a [ __ ] jungle gym it's
all yours what are you doing what am i
doing yeah so remember how we did those
addiction videos and how I can't stop
playing games ya know we're here at
blizzcon I figure hey there might be
some downtime like there is right now
hey why not bring me Seto possibly money
is sweet sure the history's greatest
month [ __ ] this is not conducive to
putting a Diskin with this design to the
PlayStation 4 in mind uh the box had it
for 360 okay but monkey s4 fits pretty
well um oh man is awesome so is this
1080 isn't any seats does it really get
up it's at ten 80 60 yes sure no that's
horseshit it's this thing avoiding these
guys are talking yeah
I have a headset I've got one I don't
step on my destiny box that's precious
we're supposed to be covering blizzards
this is activision check out that bliss
cone
a lot of people's over there it'll be
over there and out there skipper just
hanging out it could also be waiting to
get him first tomorrow yeah it's
possible they didn't go really good st.
down there
oh that's pretty tame oh wow hello
usually it's build up
people must have wised up where they
must have streamlined their ticketing
process what time is an effort Oh like
was it like seven man if I ok I didn't
open a while ago so suites are you doing
buddy need to get your badge yes I do I
with a side thank you very much hey hey
don't tell me right now yes can we not
turning off you want put all I there are
you afraid that I'm gonna yeah yeah
don't don't cut don't pepper spray me I
got [ __ ] I have a problem with authority
figures he's got pink hair yeah all
right Donnie O'Dwyer gamespot role of
GameSpot Maliki's sweet don't tell you
could have been an IGN fam you might
have just gone straight for the spray I
don't know kind of yeah the whole thing
day by day just I want us justice nice
to finally put a face to the name so
Andrew Andrew Justin yep
yes that's me no we don't know no one
else no one else yes thank you very much
appreciate it
what it is house will be giving these
away probably on the lobby maybe maybe I
don't know yep Twitter or the lobby I
don't know whenever we get swag it's
always goes on to Cynthia where his desk
when she she finds a home for it takes
to sing
good
crazy
me
hey
well it's my news desk today with the
new announcement to give us dead
you